it was interesting the term binging at
first when people started talking about
Netflix binging I thought that would be
a bad term for Netflix it sounds very
pathological and I don't know if that
sounds very healthy and fun but it
actually took hold and we went with the
flow we didn't invent the term but we do
lead to people binging through lots of
TV shows to us binging is really about
consumer control it's not about someone
telling you you only get one hour a week
and we're gonna slowly parse it out of
the story that you're enjoying hold on
I'll scenes from next week tune in next
Sunday at 8 o'clock it's not about that
it's about giving the control back to
the consumer here's the whole story now
watch as much as you want you know it's
been I think 170 years since anyone
published a book I can't maybe they're
examples online but it's very rare where
they go really giving you one chapter
next week we'll give you the next
chapter they give you the whole book you
can read as much as you want or as
little as you want on any given day and
that's fine and that's the way TV should
be give me the whole frickin story and
then I could watch as much as little as
I want
so with that has led to some interesting
behaviors yes there are people when we
released the show whether a new season
of orange is the new black comes out or
house of cards or narcos people will
there are there is a tiny minority of
people who will just binge through the
whole thing in the exact amount of time
from the second we launched it at
midnight California time they'll examine
the hours are in the show they'll
exactly finish and that's a tiny percent
most people watch two to three episodes
in an evening sometimes longer on
weekends and it really depends on the
show and it really depends on the
consumer because what you might consider
Benjy and what I might consider binging
could be two very different things me it
could be a crazy binge to watch two
whole episodes oh my god in one night
and you it might be binge it's like
seven episodes in tonight if I don't go
to sleep 3 a.m. and you know I'm falling
asleep in front of the TV and pregnant
Lee generally onto the side of my mouth
and I haven't really done a full all-out
bench
you